all right you know how this goes right
yep hey guys i'm ryan wright hold on
yes mike's on hey guys i'm ryan wright
i'm jeremy jeremy is new to the channel
first dude i'm having on the channel and
i figure
what better do you to have on than
someone who's this good looking okay so
today we're going to be watching some
transformers tv spots and you know
transformers has mark wahlberg in it so
who better to bring on than pain and
gain over here that's what's up yeah man
yeah did you see painting i did see that
yeah
that was my favorite movie oh my god
do you see his junk mark wahlberg yeah
dude he has a nice bulge no he does have
a nice bulge yeah i knew he'd be great
to bring on the channel because we have
similar interests
this guy's a personal trainer and a
dancer and [ __ ] i'm going to show you
some pictures of jeremy right now
i want to look at these photos with you
i want i want to see your body oh
goodness while i'm next to you this guy
i'm kind of awkward oh these are
probably old pictures too
yo
no way of the way people who say that i
don't upload any new ones way better now
actually even though i'm pretty amazing
at this photo photos
dan dude you're like even skinnier here
look how beautiful you look here [ __ ]
man that is i am so envious you probably
get so much [ __ ] that was so jealous 20
pounds lighter than i am now i don't say
this to a lot of guys that suck your
dick oh thank you just honestly
appreciate that just i feel like people
i feel like most guys would say that
about you god really loved you when you
were made
is this straight
oh now it is i guess you guys were
crooked the whole time sorry about that
it's all good okay guys so we're gonna
start off with the first one this first
one is called transformers age of
extinction destroyer that's the name of
a transformer right is it i have no idea
but it sounds like it would be one i
don't know anything about transformers
really and a lot of people hate me for
that that's all good neither do i
they're like what happened to your
childhood all right here we go
30 seconds of awesomeness there it is
let's do this oh you're getting serious
taking off those glasses yeah i go all
super mad on people when i do that
hot chick i know you need those
dude this looks awesome i love it
oh he's right
that's [ __ ] sweet
the fire breath that was like a
transformer godzilla dude that was
awesome wow i'm already liking these
trailers a lot because i think they they
already look better than
the last transformers for sure like i
wasn't a big fan of the other did you
like the other transformers i mean i
like the entertainment aspect of it when
it came to i guess people said it didn't
compare to how transformers are supposed
to be shown i hear that a lot but it was
very entertaining a lot of explosions i
guess that's how michael bay does it in
slow motion i want a transformers movie
that's about the transformers yeah not
about the people yeah the humans yeah i
agree it would be nice to see where the
personalities of the transformers are
really shining yeah so yeah i mean who
knows maybe they'll do that a little bit
more in this one or not so next one
we're gonna watch is called um forge
whatever that means oh i know what it
means but with the trailer tv spot
number seven
spottage
sport is your dick
spotted
wow that arm
what was that uh
there it is
a spaceship
oh yes do i think mark while we're gonna
make it much better actually that's why
i'm looking forward to it because it is
mark wahlberg and he hasn't really
messed up a lot of movies no no he's
been in i've actually enjoyed his
company even in the movies that are not
so great that he does he still tends to
be pretty enjoyable to watch he's very
consistent like that
yeah [ __ ] pop-ups man man it's all
good man some things just kind of pop up
you know what i mean yeah yeah it scared
the [ __ ] at me when i was in middle
school
better probably attract a lot of females
though yeah it's the scent really ah i
have really good smelling semen that's
what i'm trying to tell you guys
so all you ladies out there ah you smell
that yeah
that's his
talking about mine smells like marijuana
like
a lot of marijuana hey
you never know some that could be a good
flavor it is a great flavor always gets
the girl really happy afterwards and
calm at the same time yeah yeah i know
that's that's the best part about my
what you're seeing about my semen kind
of enticing like i'm pretty sure i'm
curious
i'll let you try something someday ah
yeah alrighty you know before i came on
i was like i usually hit on the girls
that come on the channel what what am i
going to talk about with a guy and it's
it's somehow becoming exactly what i
talk like on the girls on the channel
that's how it should be yeah we're very
comfortable with each other no it's the
way it's supposed to be
he's going to train me
boom yeah
that's a delayed boom
all right so we're going to check out
this last tv spot called help oh here we
go i'm assuming people are going to be
in danger in this one unlike the other
trailers yeah man explosions messing up
buildings yeah mark wahlberg doing his
mark thing oh you think he's gonna be
shirtless i hope so oh my gosh there's
better be at least one shirtless he
needs to be especially after pain and
gain he's the buffest like farmer father
i've ever seen yeah no straight up all
right so we're gonna get some help here
nice pun
you guys have never seen a truck like
this before
i think we just found a transformer i
think we just found a transformer
see mark over can be an action hero yeah
oh my goodness yeah dude [ __ ] um i
love his deep voice autobots the action
looks better ah it looks way better it
looks like you can really see what's
going on it looks crisp and clean dude
[ __ ] excited
it almost looked like a little bit of jj
abrams in it just a bit tiny bit like a
tiny little bit just
in there how's that novel coming along
brian
it's going down very well actually all
right
that was not a brian actually yeah i'm
still stupid
all right guys well yeah transformers
what more can you say i mean i've seen a
bunch of clips already and that looks
and still looks like the [ __ ] but if
you're new to the channel um this button
up here subscribe you could lick it
yeah i like watching you do that when
you like talk yeah check out my tongue
wow
good for you that's a pretty decent lead
that's a long tongue
i get that's what she said yeah that is
what she said that one actually applied
i'm surprised i didn't come up with that
yeah
you should have been on that ninety
percent time i say that's what she said
people like what doesn't even make sense
and jeremy he's launching his own
channel what are you watching um in a
couple days a couple days okay then [ __ ]
it there's probably a subscribe button
here for him now so check it out i would
say you're gonna click on your dick but
you can't see your dick right now oh
yeah yeah that's a reference to another
thing he's not just talking about
clicking on my dick check out his
channel he does he's an awesome dancer
too here here's some footage of him
dancing
right no you're an insane dancer the way
your body moves you must like if i was
about to get laid like right before i'm
about to like have sex with her and then
she's like just so you know one time i
had sex with jeremy shine i'd be like no
thank you i'm gonna disappoint the hell
out of you right now i mean you you know
how to like literally kick some ass yeah
so your your legs can go real high oh
yeah i'm i'm flexible ladies i'm
flexible you hear that he's like
flexible this is got stamina and speed
and everything so i'm flexing but he's
flexible
ah
can we see your bicep for just one
second wait which one right i'm
left-handed do the right weight right
hand
yeah
yeah
all right my turn my turn go go go
nice you look so nice look at that
touch it ah dude even your forearm is
buffer than my whole bicep wouldn't that
be easy if girls would just hit on you
less like that dude if girls were just a
little bit more straightforward that
would change everything for my life why
are you playing games yeah [ __ ]
stop it god i don't get why you [ __ ]
have no respect for my dick
looks good there
yeah or he's actually not wearing pants
right now who needs to when the frame is
like this yeah exactly so shout out time
here we go shout outs the ven um king
venom's with like it's spelled like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so venom king and he said oh
i want to shout out pleasey
so yeah here's your shout out venom king
then come king van [ __ ] king this whole
video has been a lot of come talk
i wonder if his semen has venom in it
dude you don't like the girl just
i mean
i might call that something very illegal
that i don't want to bring up on this
yeah we're not going down that territory
but you know what we're talking about
you're the king you're the king man
you're the king say king of the venom
and he also said your mom looks asian
but can you give me a shout out wait a
minute wait wait your mom looks asian i
have a problem with this
but can you still give me a shout out is
that what you're implying wow so he's
senior mom oh yeah my mom we came on one
episode oh i missed that yeah i'm gonna
check that out yeah she came on
wednesday yeah i know he's slept with my
mom and he's rubbing into my face right
now
louis garcia
he said one day ryan and sally will get
drunk and
someone end the sentence for me we're
gonna [ __ ] that's simple you've seen
sally right i've seen sally sally's a
cutie it's always a cutie and one day
sally my
venom king
is going to meet your
salamander
yes
i i literally drew a blank on that one
oh man that was great we work well
together we do work well together to be
awesome the back and forth is really
panning out well well thanks lewis for
you know talking about my
secret desires you next four he said
could i have a shout out on my birthday
from sally sorry sally's not here um
it's may 30th uh
it's may 31st today coming from a pretty
girl like her would be a gift in itself
i go in order of requests so to kind of
go like hey i'm gonna put you
specifically for this would be like
going out of order and that's just i
don't have like a calendar of this [ __ ]
so i'm sorry sally's not here but you
got jeremy and he's got a hot body i
mean i'm wearing red she has red hair
yeah yeah you know i wonder if she has a
red vagina crutch
that's kind of a that's an interesting
question yeah one day i'll find out
those garcias yeah
fire crotches but just let's just think
about that for the size of giant for a
second
sorry you next four i wish you was here
now too oh well
well happy birthday
yeah
hope you have a fun one
staying in your room thinking about
sally all night